praying the rosary or the Lord's Prayer
necessary because these are spiritual
disciplines please listen to this
advice you need to be discipline to have
a regular spiritual daily program of
spiritual exercise we need to exercise
spiritually not just physically your
spiritual exercise is daily prayers so
Rosary Lord's Prayer daily Bible
meditation fasting going to the
Eucharist all right that is your
spiritual exercise but then you need
prayers from your heart prayers that are
flowing from what you're feeling and
thinking because you have a relationship
with a living savior who's more real
than you can imagine who's with you
every second every minute who knows what
you think and feel and wants you to
speak to him as a
friend okay so if all you're doing is
Rosary that's not enough all you're
doing is daily Bible reading meditation
it's not enough you need to speak to him
speak to him commune with him so when
you drive and you're hurt tell the Lord
Lord I'm hurt right now would you
comfort me Lord would you take over the
wheel of the car Lord would you guide me
to where you want me to go Lord I'm
angry Lord I hate this person Lord I'm
upset talk to him he's your friend
so rope prayer is important that's your
spiritual discipline the more you do it
it becomes second nature but you got to
do more than that Brethren many of us
will do rot prayer right meaning
repetitive prayer and that's it no
that's not it the way your love grows
for someone is by spending time with
them in their presence having
communion
okay the more you have fellowship with
someone the more you get to know that
person and the more you realize whether
that person is lovely lovable and with
your time or
not why do you think relationships fail
give you an analogy please bear with me
we got a lot to talk about Sonia don't
sleep today I need to talk because I
feel the spirit leading
me sometimes you meet someone you don't
know and you fall for them but when you
then get to know them you see what a
mistake you made and you regret your
decision hence divorce
Jesus is someone that the more you get
to know the more irresistible he becomes
the more beautiful he becomes the more
lovely he becomes the more you fall in
love with
him you get my
point Focus do not engage anyone Lucen
Focus are you with me there he's the
type of person that the more you get to
know him the more you fall in love with
him the more beautiful he becomes the
more lovely and you realize the best
thing you did was to trust in him and
fall in love with him human
relationships are not like that
sometimes we meet someone we're
attracted to their personality that we
see at that moment or their looks but
when we spend more time we see how
damaged they are how repulsive they are
and we regret it that will never
happened with Jesus those who leave
Jesus is because they didn't truly know
him there are people in Ministry pastors
who don't know Jesus they
don't they will talk about him they'll
expound the Bible they'll say prayers
but they don't know him because they're
not walking with him they're not talking
to him they're not communing with him
because to them it's a job or to them
they think they are in fellowship with
the Lord because they're teaching and
they're count no that's no
no it has to be a daily
communion daily talking to the Lord
daily speaking to him when you're
driving you talk to him when you're
sitting on your couch you talk to him
you get up in the morning fall on your
face and thank him speak to
him talk to him commune with him and let
his words sink in your ears remind
yourself and recall his words I am the
way the truth and the life my peace I
give to you come to me all those things
should be playing in your
mind right and I'm not boasting about
myself just an example if I'm sad I'll
sit I say Lord I'm sad right now please
help me Lord you know I'm weak if I'm
being tempted with lust Lord please help
me I'm I'm lusting Lord I don't want to
anger you please I love you Lord please
help me speak to him and then take a
moment out of your day and tell him I
love you okay tell him I love
you right there are moments where my
heart is overflowing with joy and I say
Aba I love you Lord Jesus I love you
Holy Spirit I love you thank you Lord
thank you Lord tell
him right Focus okay don't change the
how many of you parents Delight when
your children run up to you and say
Mommy I love
you Daddy I love you and how many
children Delight when they hear their
parents saying I love you you're my joy
the same thing with your heavenly father
your older brother and the Holy Spirit
take a
moment daily to say
Lord I just want to tell you he knows
your heart but he wants you to verbalize
it the Bible is all about verbalizing it
if you confess with your lips your mouth
he wants you to say it right you can
even say it in your heart he hears Lord
I love
you Son of God I love you Lord Jesus I
couldn't make it without you thank you
Lord for being too good to me I know I
don't deserve it and Lord please never
leave me because I can't do without you
I can't live without
you that's how you speak to your God if
you're just doing rot repetitive
repetitive prayer you're not having
Fellowship
imagine the only conversations you have
with your life is a certain speech that
you repeat every day and that's it and
doesn't go beyond that or your spouse
that's not going to cut it there are
things you do regularly and your
relationship but then there are things
that have to be spontaneous and From The
Heart Don't Treat God as some distant
being the Lord says I am with you always
till the end of the age he who loves me
will keep my command and my father will
love him and we will come to him and we
will make our home with him we will live
with you in your home John
14:23 Jesus lives with you and every one
of you the father lives with you and
every one of you and the spirit lives
with you and every one of you if you're
making the effort to stay connected by
honoring the Lord because God is not
limited the entire creation is before
him are you with me
there a
reminder are you with me
there you understand that's how your
life has to be you have a relationship
with the living Lord who's Almighty
omniscient omnipresent the entire
creation is present before him because
he's sustaining everything by his word
but he wants you to speak to
him so go beyond just the Rosary every
day good it's got to be more than that
it's got to be a real relationship where
you really because he knows what you're
thinking he knows what you you think
you're hiding the thoughts you have
whether good or bad he knows it tell him
Lord you know I'm angry right now Lord
you know I'm disgusted I'm disappointed
with whatever Lord I need your strength
I don't want upset you and then you can
even tell them Lord I don't know why
this happened why did you allow to
happen I trust you and I love you I know
who you are but sometimes things happen
and I don't understand your wisdom
behind it can you help me talk to
him talk to him just like you want your
spouse to talk to you and you want your
children to talk to you and open up with
you your heavenly father wants you to
talk to him and be open with him and
your big brother the firstborn wants you
to talk to him and be open with him and
the Holy Spirit who guides you wants you
to be open with him and to talk to him
be
honest are we getting it
are we getting
it do you want me to give you an example
of real life spontaneous prayer where
the Lord and the servants are talking to
one
another having heart-to-heart
conversation when the Lord is in heaven
you want me to give you two
examples you want me to show you that
their relationship with the Lord was
real he's in heaven glorified and
they're talking to him from their
heart can I give you an
example now watch the real interaction
between the Lord and his servants are
you ready the real
interaction watch
here and but ananas answered Lord I have
heard from many about this man how much
evil he has done to thy Saints at
Jerusalem see he's speaking his from his
heart but Lord this man has persecuted
Christians thrown them in prison see
this is a
conversation he's having a real
conversation with the Risen Lord in
glory it's not just wrot repetition our
father he didn't break out into our
father huj
conversation conversing Lord but this
man is dangerous he's a blasphemer lord
it's what he did to your people in other
words you sure you want to save him
get it Lord I've heard from many about
this man how much evil he has done to
thy Saints at Jerusalem and here he has
Authority from the chief priest to bind
all who
call upon thy name now notice he's
telling Jesus what Jesus already
knows you think Jesus doesn't know that
he's telling Jesus what Jesus already
knows what is that tell you just because
Jesus knows something doesn't mean he
doesn't want you to tell him
and doesn't mean he doesn't want to hear
it from your own
mouth are you catching
this are you catching
this the Lord stopped Paul from
persecuting Christians in Syria ananas
is telling the Lord what the Lord
already knows this is confession why
should I confess if the Lord already
knows and he's forgiven me because the
Lord wants you to confess your sin and
acknowledge your sin though he knows
your sin right he wants you to confess
it and verbalize it or at least confess
it in your heart here it is the Lord
already knows this ananas but the Lord
wants you to
express and communicate what you're
thinking and feeling though he already
knows what you're thinking and
feeling thank you nasty he has super
patience with us is it sinking in sunny
and everyone else it's got to be more
than just the rosary you got to open
your heart so what does the Lord say to
him look what Focus guys don't engage
each other
Focus but the Lord sent to him go fore
is a chosen inst of mine to carry my
name before the Gentiles and Kings and
the sons of Israel do you see how
glorious and Majestic and Almighty our
God is Jesus in heaven is aware of
everything taking place he's aware where
everyone is and he's able to show you
where someone else is and show that
person who you
are are you catching it ananas Paul is
on Straight Street notice irony notice
the street is called straight straight
Street why because now Paul is on the
straight path he was on a crooked path
but the Lord planted him on the street
that is straight straight to heaven
Straight Street notice
that and the Lord's telling an he's in
this person's house Judas and he's
praying Lord how do you know he's
praying because I am the omniscient
omnipresent omnipotent Lord who beholds
all things is aware of all things and
sustains all things